السلام عليكم ورحمه الله من الجزيره يقدم
لحضراتكم موجزا اللمبه عقد وزراء دفاع
روسيا وتركيا وسوريا مباحثات ثلاثيه في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو بمشاركه قاده
الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه في الدول الثلاث
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انه تم بحث
سبل حل الازمه السوريه هو مشكله اللاجئين
والجهود المشتركه لمكافحه ما وصفته
بالمجموعات المتطرفه على الاراضي السوريه
واضاف البيان وانه في نهايه المباحثات
اشاره المشاركون الى الطبيعه البنائه التي
جرت خلال لها المباحثات
قررت الجامعه العمه للنقل التابعه للاتحاد
العام للشغل في تونس تنفيذ اضراب عام في
قطاع النقل البري والبحري والجوي الخامس
والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من يناير
المقبل وقال الكاتب العمل الجامعي في
تصريح اذاعي قرار الاضراب جاء نتيجه تجاهل
الحكومه لمطالب النقابيين ورفض النقابيين
التام للخصخصه في المؤسسات العموميه لقطع
النقل
في المقابله تامر رئيس التونسي وقيس سعيد
بن وصفهم بالغارقين في الفساد بالسعييه
الى ضرب امن الدوله عبر اختلاق الازمات
واختلا اجتماع عندما رئيسه الحكومه وعددا
من الوزراء اضافه الى قياداتنا عسكريه قال
الرئيس سعيد ان الاوضاع التي تعيشها
البلاد اليوم وما يحصل من قبل من وصفهم
بالغارقين حتى النخاع في الفساد بضرب
مؤسسات الدوله يرقى الى جريمه التامر على
امن الدوله الداخليه والخارجيه وفقه تعبير
من جهته قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني في
تونس احمد نجيب الشابي قال ان الازمه في
البلاد تتصاعد وتتصرعوا بشكل خطير واضفت
شاب في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الجبهه تطالب
برحيل الرئيس قيس سعيد عبر انتخابات
رئاسيه مبكرا
يصوتوا الكنيسه الاسرائيليه ليوم الخميس
على الحكومه التي كلف بنيامين نتنياهو
بتشكيلها وبعد اتفاقهم مع شركائه في
الاعتلاف قال نتنياهو ان اولويته ستكون
توسيعه الاستيطان في الضفه ومواصلات الحرب
على برنامج ايران النووي من جانب الاخر
صدق على توسيعي صلاحيه ايتامار
للامن القومي
قال الكريم لانه لا وجود لخطه سلامي لدى
اوكرانيا حتى الان لان كيف لا تاخذ ما
سماه حقائقا اليوم في الاعتبار بالاعتراف
بضم روسيا للاقاليم الاربع من جانبه قلى
مستشار ورئاسه الاوكرانيه ان الثوابت
بلاده تتمثل في السعاده دومباز وشبه جزيره
القرم وكافه الاراضي التي استولت عليها
روسيا واضاف ان روسيا بدات حربا لقتل
المدنيين والاستلاء على الاراضي وما عدد
ذلك من مبررات روسيه هو محظو كذب على حد
وصفه
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]